[Music]
okay for all the data scientists out
there let's talk about Jupiter notebooks
in the cloud with collab and vertex AI
workbench first off collab offers hosted
notebooks that require no credit card
and gives a default allocation of
services at no cost while workbench is a
paid service that provides managed
notebooks meaning they come with
libraries pre-installed GPU supporters
automatic Etc colab has some usage and
Hardware limits to stay free of charge
but a paid version does provide some
additional flexibility while workbench
gives you more control over the
environment and Hardware you use
colab tends to be popular in academic
communities and for teaching purposes
like code samples while workbench is a
great option for companies needing
Enterprise grade security and deep cross
product Integrations including being
part of vertex AI platform more info
pinned in the comments